yeah because that night we showed it and
you didn't you see how this is how
you're a fair-weathered fan to that
night before this he was a max Holloway
fan but you know was so sure about or
take a hundred percent and it was just
Renzo and I sure so who were super for
max right what's the deal with Renzo man
Renzo freaks me out I gotta be honest
leather jacket
Michael Michael check it out is that
this mother for my hair cousin
horrendous Renzo isn't our camera normal
cameraman he asked to be here he's never
getting mixed much right that he is like
I was only joking man Renne is your
biggest [ __ ] he wants to suck your
dick Michael finally so don't [ __ ]
around Renzo I mean weak because we as a
family we this is a this is cultural
that what we do yeah yeah you see that
yeah we love it the caps and everything
you know like cats I'm more of a dog
person but whatever we have three dogs
there what kind of dogs they're all we
don't go tell them it's none of your
[ __ ] business
my dog was here those come really what
the dogs I'm joking I got a hippo no no
that was a very stereotypical cliched
dog choice that you picked there for me
now I'm a German Shepherd man I love
driving I got to yeah
Alfie and Harry yeah I was a little
layer what is he yoky poo or [ __ ] - he's
a little fun we have a Yorkie a Maltipoo
no mark and he just bolted multiple poos
on the [ __ ] yeah okay you love them
the same no of course I love the Jovi
Shepherd my I'm sorry
he's got my person how he just want the
stroking he just comes up and
there's nothing else okay wanting to be
strong you know it gets a little old
Alfie's got personality but we got Alfie
because dito he was my other German
Shepherd he died prior to Harry being
around we got my daughter Ellie a pug
charlie sweetest little thing you've
ever seen in your life you've got it
from my daughter and I was going to the
Fox Studios one day and as I'm walking
in I got a phone call from the wife
she's like oh Michael bagel bagel I'm
like what Herot charlie was eating
details food and the German Shepherd got
the POG and shocked him he's not moving
in his I take him to the vets take him
to the vet her to the vet she's yeah
we're on our way there so I walk into
the Fox Studios and Brian Stann you know
Brian Stann yeah he's there and I'm
freaking out I'm not holy [ __ ] this was
liquor literally as I was walking in and
I'm walking I'm out fog and it was like
what's wrong I'm like my [ __ ] dog
Charlie you might be dying she might be
dying you know blah blah blah blah blah
tell the whole story I'm Brad sounds
like are you [ __ ] serious I've got
brothers dying in Afghanistan and you
expect me to give a [ __ ] about your doc
I'm like Obama when you put it like that
yes Daddy yeah yeah it's my daughter's
[ __ ] POG and she's cute it's also not
listen to me dude I want to see that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] he did that who my dog
no Brian
some people have worse things going on
in their life but it doesn't mean what
you're going is less than I know I know
I know it's crazy this guy Brian Stanny
yeah yeah yeah I really am
what do you say when he said his name I
go I go yeah I know him I don't know
that guy know him
Google a photo because he's gonna be on
my [ __ ] death wish he's a good guy
strong he's a good guy who's too hard
he's a father I don't want that sorry
but you get emotional kids here that was
all Michaels did say what's his name
Brian Brian Stann Sam I love you sorry
Charlie he sees it times when a dog dies
he like your dog died oh yeah we had to
put it down Goddard devastated well she
was really mature about it because I got
her on the phone I said you know because
the vet said we need to put Charlie down
that's okay let me speak to my daughter
first so I got her on the phone I said
listen Ellie you know it's not looking
good I explained the whole situation I
said so what they're gonna do is they're
gonna give her an injection and she
won't feel any pain and she'll actually
feel kind of nice you know that's how it
works and you'll fall asleep and she'll
just never wake up you know as you got
into college no no she was 12 at that
out well or 11 even oh my and she was
trying not to cry okay okay and that was
the word that set me off oh my god
because she was so mature about it you
know but he was trying not to cry it
broke my heart so then we got hairy
there's like a little replacer you know
which you shouldn't do but whatever you
know Lucas wanted a dog that's my
youngest yeah yes anything happened to
Harry but he survived but he's only got
one eye so Wow - dog balls detail
Charlie they were on the floor the
German the little guy way in the big guy
the big guy said [ __ ] you so we got this
thing where the German chefs food is up
high and the little dog's food is down
low so they can't get it one and it was
working a treat
we obviously kept an eye on it for a
while and then it was working so we're
all good but then there was a leak okay
and there was a leak in the house I'm
here to [ __ ] take everything out the
laundry and put it outside and when we
put everything outside we put it on the
floor because there was water going
everywhere and as we're doing that oh
[ __ ] so let me get this we survived
Michael let me hurry one I think is
about let me get this straight and he's
happy
what was the dog that died was it what
was her name
so Charlie right we like to get very
Vanaras each bit Charlie right new Tobit
Junko Vito peach bit bit Charlie Charlie
died right then Vito was that's a name
yeah you got another dog yeah by the
name of what Harry Harry
Vito did the same thing to the new dog
yeah you didn't learn from the first
time [ __ ] nut what did I just say I said
I said we got different things W should
have come down you should know no
there's no I now right he's happy you
knows no way to know that by the way
okay there was a dog communicated with
them and I said yo what's up with your
Isaac I don't know my [ __ ] owners or
a [ __ ] [ __ ] up there was a guy that
died earlier it's not gonna help me oh
you say these don't look [ __ ] happy
that was looking sideways he's like
where's the camera but that's that's the
new dog that's the new one that's alpha
the big one okay all right okay the
biter passed away
[Music]